you know when you talk about motivation
of uh money and glamour
a guy comes to mind and i don't know how
many wrestlers you know but
in russia there's a guy named uh bovaci
of the satir brothers one of the
greatest
freestyle wrestlers of all time but he
also has um
it's funny he doesn't have many
interviews one of my goals is to go out
and talk to him in russian
do an interview with him because he's
exceptionally poetic
and a deep thinker he's uh the kind of
martial artist that you are
in the way that it's not just about the
the different battles you've been
through or whatever
it's about the philosophy behind the way
he approaches life
and he he's spoken quite a bit about
that the
the glamour the fame the money are all
things that get in the way
of um the purity of the experience the
art
that the way to achieve greatness is to
just
lose yourself in the art of the actual
combat in this case it's wrestling
and then kind of not to worry and
actively
make sure that you block out anybody who
you know feeds you the narrative where
you're supposed to be this famous person
it's all those kinds of things that he
basically says let others
write your story i make sure that you
just focus on the art
and now another person from that side of
the world is
of course khabib so he represents that
side of the world and we were talking
about walking away
and most people not being able to walk
away
at the top as you have but also now
could be has it looks like incredibly so
so
i mean maybe you can comment about what
your thoughts are
about uh khabib nurmagomedov being able
to just
walk away you know we talk about the
goat very often
khabib is you know one of isn't the
argument
because he has the most dominant
carrier of all martial art guy
you know some guys can be named the goat
for different reasons but khabib
for that reason and he's undefeated he
i don't even know if he lost might have
lost
round but he'd dominate
all his opponent it was ridiculous and
such an incredible career that he had um
i love to watch him fight is incredible
and when you talk about the art when you
say mixed martial art
the idea of a
flawless performance for me
everybody often when we say flawless
performance
thinks about a knockout a brutal
knockout
but for me it's it's to be able
to showcase beautiful technique
like a beautiful takedown beautiful
submission be
like something beautiful that
you know when you you look at for
example uh
wayne gretzky or michael jordan or
like stephen curry or so
even if you don't know nothing about
basketball and you watch
michael jordan you'll be like wow that's
beautiful what you just did
like we talked about fighting and and
trying to say
the the word beautiful and fighting for
certain people it could sound
kind of crazy you know but but i'm
talking about the technique
a beautiful technique you know for me
that's the goal
you know when i was fighting it's not
only to to have a brutal knockout
because some people are more gifted than
others and so
i'm saying gifted some people are better
than others in certain
phases of fighting but for me it was
that it was to showcase to win
of course but to showcase some beautiful
technique that that that you can watch
watch it and be like wow that was
incredible the timing
did it
you